are just some of the words that I've
come up with that feminist just like
make up to confuse everybody number one
now I know there's technical definitions
that you could look up for these things
but let's just be honest
this is defined as sexual contact or
behavior that occurs without the
explicit consent to the victim so when I
hear
I think of like something great or
something crazy but now I'm finding out
lump in all of these
where it's defined on consent and what
what is consent consent means to give
permission now on paper this sounds good
but I I think we can see how in romantic
setting be a bit confusing like do you
need written permission and can it be
body language like there's so much stuff
between the lines so basically start to
lose what this really means